[Music]
you
so welcome back friends we are now into
the second lecture on decision making
and as you know decision making is a
complex process compressed quality
process so it follows from reasoning and
and judgment and so in the last lecture
on decision making what we saw is what
is decision-making and so the definition
that I provided you there is that this
isn't making is make basically a process
of making a choice among a number of
alternatives which have been given by
the judgment process now when we make
this choice in in decision-making this
generally happens in terms of or in in
the presence of some kind of a risk or
some kind of a uncertainty and the
reason that people make or the reason
for these uncertainties that people make
decision into is the fact that people
are humans that humans do not have all
the information which is necessary for
calculating a choice for calculating the
effectiveness of a choice and so they
tend to run into irrationality or
irrationality of choices beside that we
also discussed the idea of something
called expected utility theory and this
expected neutral theory which has been
borrowed from economics basically
suggests that people's choice which are
which should be rational or ideal is
basically dependent on the utility of a
particular option and the probability of
happening of this option now what do I
mean by this no generally this is in
making models that we tend to study and
at this level are two in nature the
first kind of decision-making models are
called the normative models are the
prescriptive models and the prescriptive
models are those models of
decision-making which are supposed to be
followed or which are supposed to be
utilized in making a decision so given
the fact that judgment has given us four
or five different choices which are in
front of us the normative model provides
us certain guidelines which needs to be
followed for making choices and if we
follow and it is a guarantee that if we
follow these guidelines the choice all
will
be rational know what is a rational
choice a rational choice is the one
which give bridge guarantees that ain't
meant of a final goal and it gives us
the maximum gain or it maximizes our
gain and also minimizes our losses so it
is a choice in which the gain
the chances of gains are there but then
the transfer losses are very minimum and
so rational choices are those choices
which provides maximum utility in the
presence of maximum probability of
occurrence of an even know an expected
utility theory the idea of expectancy
says that joy those choices which
provide us the maximum utility then for
a particular option and with the
availability the highest probability of
that option happening is the most
rational choice what do I mean by this
given the fact that there are four or
five different choices which which come
out of a particular cognition now what
we tend to do is rate the utility of
each choices each choices present a
certain goodness or sources are certain
benefits and certain downside of it so
what we tend to do is look at the
benefit of each choice and the downside
of it and equate them this is called
utility or the the use of a particular
choice with that each of this option
will also have a probability of
occurence for example some of these
choices tend to occur more frequently
than the other number of choices or the
other kind of choices so an irrational
choice are according to the expected
utility theory the rational choice will
be a choice which has maximum
occurrences the highest probability of
occurrences and also the highest
expected utility now given the fact that
some choices have very high utility and
very low probability we should not make
this choices we should only make those
choices which which has a decent amount
of probability of occurring and also
give us a decent amount of utility so if
a choice has highest probability of
occurring but it gives us the very low
utility we should not chose this choice
on the other hand if a choice has
highest utility and lowest occurrence we
should not make that choice
a rational decision-maker will make a
choice which gives them a certain level
of utility and also a very good level of
probability of occurence and so this is
what the expected utility theory really
works now the problem is this expected
utility theory are always violated by
humans the reason being that humans
don't have enough information are not
calculators not statisticians to
calculate all the options on which to be
the choices to be made and so they go
under or they violate these principles
of expected utility and they create
violations of them and one of the
violations that we discussed in the last
class is called preference reversal
which basically means that if if people
tend to prefer choice a in certain
situation they reverse their choice in
certain situation B or C know the
reference reversal theory says that if
somebody likes choice a or somebody
likes option a better than B then no
matter how the situation changes it
should stick with it but then as humans
we do not stick to that which keep on
changing our preference from situation
to situation and so this is a violation
or the expected utility theory now why
does this happen
the reason I've given before this
happens because humans do not have all
the information which is necessary for
making the computations and neither even
if they have the information they are
lazy or they have some kind of a
deficiency in organizing all this
information and coming up with the best
choices and so humans then do not follow
the normative or the prescriptive model
of generally do not follow the
prescriptive model of decision-making so
then what do they follow they follow a
model of descriptive model of
decision-making
what is the descriptive model the
descriptive model of decision-making is
a model which generally humans follow
while making decisions and it has it at
times tends to give originality or
choices of irrationality so people then
tend to make choices which are low yield
and tend to then suffer and so this this
kind of people's choice is making or
people's decision making are not always
rational
they are irrational and under this
irrationality is not too much of a harm
to people and so what are the theories
which has been proposed by the Nobel
prize-winner with Travis key and
Kahneman in 1979 what's called a
prospect theory this is a descriptive
model of decision-making and it takes
into account of the fact that humans are
different from computers and they don't
generally have these expected utilities
and probabilities combining and making
decisions onto it so then let's look at
what is prospectively now one of the
propeller alternate is to the expected
utility theory is provided by a Nobel
Prize winner Daniel Kahneman with his
colleague and Amos Tversky in 1979 and
which is called the prospect theory what
is the prospect theory say the prospect
theory it's a descriptive model of
decision-making that attempts to
describe how we make decisions and why
our decisions violate the expected
utility model and so what is the
statement of this theory the statement
of this theory says that decisions are
not valued based on an absolute value of
the end result the way we make decisions
generally are not valued if stability is
not valued as in terms of what the end
result would be or what the final value
attained after the decision choices
should be but this theory passed
proposed by expectedly theory instead we
value decisions based on the amount of
gain or loss from what we have right now
so people don't look at decisions or
people don't look at the utility of a
decision or the desirability of a
decision in terms of the end value in
terms of the final value that you're
going to get but people make decisions
in terms of the value that they're going
to get from where they are from the
reference point of where they are so
people make these value decisions in
terms of the amount of gain or loss that
they are going to have from the point of
time or from the point where people are
right now so let's take that take the
fact that if playing a gamble gives you
10 rupees and if you lose that or if you
don't if you win that gamble yet
if you lose the gamble you get you lose
ten rupees then in terms of expected in
to be theory the Tetra please is the
final value and so that is what the this
isn't criteria should be followed on to
that but then we as humans we decide
this this ten rupees the value ten
rupees is not the same value on which
you make decisions what we tend to do is
even the fact that if you have five
rupees in your pocket what you tend to
do is that the expected value or the
expected value of this outcome then
becomes five rupees because this is
because if you have if you lose still
you will have five rupees which is with
you and so it doesn't matter too much so
from where you are standing
from there you look at the final price
so winning ten rupees when you have five
rupees is not that lucrative in terms or
the fact that if you lose the ten rupees
right and so that is the difference
which is there so in terms of prospect
theory what people tend to do is make
these evaluations of final value of an
outcome not based on the final value
from the starting point but from the
reference point from the point of how
much they have at the point of making
decisions so when you're making a
decision at that point of time how much
good that you have or how much a backup
that you have from there we make the
assessment of gains and losses on to any
gamble it also adds that gains and
losses are on different scales of value
so one thing that the problem that the
prospect theory says is that people do
not make evaluations of gains and losses
right from the beginning to the end
value of a gamble of n value of a
decision but what they tend to do is
these decisions are based or based on
the fact that how much people have
previously are people how much good
people have before they make a decision
so somebody who has money and whose
gambling he will gamble more or less
depending on how much money he has but
somebody who has no money in his choices
will be different so people do not make
this kind of a calculations in absolute
terms but rather from a reference point
the second prediction of the prospect
theory is that the guy
and losses are on different skills or
value for example the scale of value the
in terms of gains people perceive gains
as lower value but losses has higher
value so losing ten rupees note gives
you more losses or lets you feel that
you have lost more then in terms of
gaining ten rupees given the fact that
if today morning you get a ten rupees
note from somewhere you the amount of
happiness that you get will not be
equivalent to the fact that if you lose
ten rupees and at some point of time so
the amount of feeling the amount of
happiness the amount of happiness the
gain will not be equivalent to the
sadness that you get out of losing that
value and so this is the kind of things
or this is the kind of predictions in
the prospect theory actually goes ahead
and predicts now the value of your
attached to gain increases more slowly
as a function of the size of the gain
then does the negative value we place on
the loss as a function of the size of
the loss and so what it basically says
is that the gain as the amount of gain
increases the function of gain increases
very slowly so larger gains will slow I
will show you smaller increase in
happiness whereas even smaller losses we
show larger increase in sadness so if
even so if you gain fifty rupees the
amount of happiness that you get and if
you gain hundred rupees the change in
happiness from gaining fifty rupees and
hundred rupees will be sloppily in
contrast to the fact that if you lose
ten rupees and if you lose five rupees
in terms of the drop in terms of the
sadness that you get in losing ten
rupees then in five rupees the drop is
very sharp that then in terms of gains
so people will be more or less same
happy when they gain 100 rupees in fifty
rupees but if they lose five rupees in
ten rupees the amount of different
sadness that they feel will be more and
that is what one of the predictions of
this particular theory is now basically
what this theory says is that we feel
losses more act acutely than we feel
gain and so as humans in terms of
expected utility theory if we gain ten
or if we lose 10 rupees the value of
that money is still 10 rupees but then
and so we should feel the same amount of
happiness and sadness but as humans you
know that we losing money gives us more
pain and so losses are more dramatic or
gives us more sadness then if you gain
10 rupees and that is one of the more
prediction so we feel more losses
acutely so the losses are felt more
accurately then we feel guess now the
psychological pain associated by losing
a dollar 50 is greater than
psychological pleasure of gaining a
fifty dollar and that is the basic
concept or that is the basic standpoint
of the prospect theory as against the
expected utility theory which says that
gains and losses and in terms of value
say 50 rupees is lost a 50 rupee is
gained in both of them the expected
utility that we get or the rational
choice rational decision maker will not
be hindered by his preferences but a
prospect theory says that if 50 rupees
is lost we feel more sad and we don't
want to spend more money out of it but
if we gain 50 rupees we are not that
much happy and so this is the invariance
which is there or this is the kind of
difference which is there now prospect
theory predicts that people will be
especially aversive to losses and will
show differences in preference depending
on how our enemies are presented or
frame so basically another interesting
feature of this prospect theory is the
fact that people do not like losses they
are averse into loss so people do not
like losses at all and so given the fact
that if two options if a particular
option is framed differently is what it
differently people will change their
preferences so if an option has a gain
frame which means that it talks about
everything with certainty people will
have a different kind of a response or
people will choose a different kind of
an option whereas if something is framed
in a negative sense or something talks
about losing some statement talks or
some options talk about losing people
will have an entirely
option to choose from and this basic
tract is called framing so look at this
graph this graph basically says that
this is the reference point and in terms
of these are the losses and these are
the gains and this is the value so in
terms of value if you see that for
higher values as the value goes high the
gains are very less but then even for
very smaller values the loss drop is
very high so people in general they do
not like losses and losses are perceived
as bad losses of perceivers ever see
people want to avoid losses and people
but on the other hand gains even if a
very high amount of money is given to
you you gain a high amount of money you
will not become happy so the amount of
happiness that comes with gains is not
equivalent to the amount of sadness
which comes with losses so a couple of
facts to be remembered once this the
other the fact to remember is that
people hate avoiding going into losses
and so there are different scales of it
and the third thing is that if frame
differently if the same option is framed
differently people are presented
differently people Reavers their choices
sue them let's look at something called
framing what is framing framing is the
term which is used to describe the
effects on our decisions of how our
scenario is presented let's say an
option is given to you and the
presentation is the option is reworded
one so something and let's say the
option of winning of 50 rupees or winner
or or let's say that there is a
particular decision that has to be made
and out of this this is a certain kind
of choice is that certain kind of
alternatives come up now these
alternatives can be framed in a game
frame which means that everything is
positive or it can be or everything that
the alternate is talk about is certain
or it could be in a loss frame in the
sense that everything that the alternate
talk about is uncertain in nature and in
those cases people tend to reverse their
preference so prospect theory it
predicts that our preferences will
change whenever our reference point
Changez if we are in a grave frame if
they are doing evaluations if we are
choosing alternatives and options in a
grain frame then in those cases the kind
of decisions that we make and if we are
doing evaluations we are choosing
options in a lost frame those two
decisions will be different the reason
being that gains are taken in in a
different in different way than losses
gains are not that pleasant as losses
are - more sadness
so decisions can be influenced by how
information is presented and this is
what is framing framing is basically
using a say statement or basically
reframing rewording a particular option
now if information is presented in terms
of a positive or a gain frame we will be
more likely to avoid risk we will be
risk aversive and pick up a sure bet so
if something is given to our some option
is given to us in a gain frame in a
positive frame or in with certainty that
something is going to happen we are we
become risk aversive so in terms of the
fact that if certain options are given
to us which show certain amount of
certainty which have a gain frame which
has some positive outcome out of it we
tend to avoid losses in those cases as
against those so however if the same
information is presented in a negative
frame in a loss frame a certain amount
of information is given to you or
certain information which is available
in a particular option is in a loss
frame which means that certain ideas
certain level of certainty is not
provided to you we will be taking more
risk so people take more risk when a
loss frame is there when people know
that something is negative when people
know that they are losing they take more
risk but when people know that they are
gaining maybe people know that there is
no loss to it people always select sure
bets so this is what framing is all
about so it is all about how do we go
ahead and make this kind of a choices or
this kind of a thing so in a gain frame
people avoid risk right and they become
risk aversive in a loss frame in a frame
where people know that certain kind of
losses are there people take more risk
so people become a more risk flown
people take more risk in terms of
negative
in terms of negative situations in terms
of positive situations people always
prefer a sure bet consider so I'm
presenting a study by a very famous
study by Travis Kane camera in 1981 and
this is available everywhere and this
study what it does it is a sample study
to show that framing has this effect or
framing can lead to this reversal of
preferences among people and so what is
this subject in this particular study
subjects they're shown two different
kind of options which was there so two
different kind of options are presented
two or two different scenarios
represented to people let's look at the
option so the optional scenario says
that imagine that the United States is
preparing an odd break for an unusual
Asian disease so basically this is what
it is now which is expected to kill 600
people so the situation says that United
States is basically preparing a
situation or preparing themselves for an
Asian outbreak of disease where they
have already calculated the 600 people
are going to die now two alternative
programs for combating the disease have
proposed so there are two options for
combating these disease are there so 600
people are going to die no matter what
this is the certainty with it now assume
that the exact scientific estimate of
the consequence of the program is as
follows so there are two scientific
options there are two or scientific
estimates that there are two options to
look at and then you have to choose
which are the option you would like to
go with now if you adopt program a 200
people will be saved if program B is
adopted there is one-third probability
that 600 people will be saved and 2/3
probability that no one will be saved
this is one way one thing to be looked
at so 600 people were going to die out
of it and so two programs induced to
save more number of people in option A
in using the option a what happens is
that there is your sort fact that 200
people are going to be saved if program
a is rapid but if program B is adapted
then there is one third of a probability
that 600 people will be saved and
two-third of probability that no one
will be saved this is one option so one
group of subjects were present
this kind of an option another group of
subjects represented a similar option
and they were asked to make the choice
whether they will go with program a a
program B now in the other group of
subjects were presented a similar kind
of situation in which a prostate ate
that program C is adopted 400 people are
going to die but a program D is adopted
one-third probability that nobody will
die and 2/3 probably there 600 people
will die now look at these two options
which I think so basically the situation
is that there is a scenario which has
been presented the u.s. is suffering
from some kind of an attack 600 people
expected to be die dead and so they
create a hypothetical set programs two
hypothetical situations for combating
with these diseases and so these are the
options so as you look into it
the first option the first two options
program a and B we went to first kind of
subjects as in a in a game frame and in
the C and D are in the lost frame what
do you expect to happen it'll happen is
that when things are presented in the
gain frame most people select option a
which is 200 people will be saved
rather than selecting program B which
says that one-third probability that 600
people will be saved in 2/3 probability
that no one will be saved but look at
this look at the C and D option it is
presented in a loss frame and here it
says that if C doctor is R opted 400
people are going to die and where D is
adopted one-third probability that
nobody will die and 2/3 probably that
600 people will die if you look into it
there is no change from A to B right it
is the same but if provided in a gain
frame people select option A whereas if
provided in the lost frame people adopt
B as the answer and this happens this
shift or reversal of choosing D over C
or choosing a over B is from the fact
that it is framed in a different way it
is presented in different a positive or
negative frames so in a positive frame
people select those option which
presents alternately so 200 people save
certain thing I'll go with it
but the fact that if it's a lost frame
if wanted people are going
to die on own why not go with the rescue
option which says that one-third
property that nobody will die so
one-third probably that nobody will die
is going to be the same thing it's not
going to be different in any way 200
people is what is the one-third
probability that is there and so people
select the option whereas in the first
case people select a option and this
basic demonstration shows that people
show this kind of a preference reversal
or reversal of choices for yourself
which options to go with depending on
which frame it is being presented to
remember the invariance theorem which
counsel expected interim it says that if
people select a in first case they
should select C in the second case
although they are the same but that's
not what happens people reverse their
choices and this happens because these
options have been presented in different
frames or in different wordings in a
gloss frame and in a gain frame so in a
gain frame in the first case what
happens is people become more
risk-averse see they do not want to
taste this so they go with a certainty
option they go with option where two
hundred people are going to be dead but
in case where is the last frame people
go with a more risky option they take
more risk so although they will even if
we calculate is going to be the same so
take a more risky option and in this
case they take the B option which is
more risky but it is going to they think
that it is going to say more people but
it is almost the same and that isn't
very very interesting finding of this
prospect theory which says that gains
and losses are valued differently or
they are seen of person differently by
people now another interesting phenomena
or another interesting output of the
prospect theory is something called
psychological accounting it is another
interesting output of the prospect
theory or one of those features or one
of those ways in which people make
decisions and what does it says so this
principle says that people will make
different choices depending on how the
outcome is felt or perceive basically
how people feel so it is about feeling
it is about emotion it is about how
people like a particular option so the
way they feel about an option that
decides how
people are going to make the decisions
and so people feel feelings about a
particular option makes the final choice
of the decision and not the utility so
people do not go ahead and make
statistical calculations of probability
in utility in making decisions rather
what they do is they use a heuristic
approach of how they feel about a
particular choice and based on that they
make the decision and actually make the
choices of what to do with and they
consider that to be rational now look at
there are two situations which I have
presented to you to explain
psychological accounting first first of
all let us look at the first case now
imagine that you decided to see a play
for which dollar 10 a ticket and you
enter the theatre you discovered that
you have lost dollar 10 bill would you
pay $10 for the ticket to the plane the
so the first option is that you have
lost a $10 bill which means that you
have lost the money and so you enter
into a theatre you want to go see a
movie you enter a theatre and then in
after entering a theatre you lost a $10
thing which is also the cost of the
ticket so are you going to pay for the
ticket are you going to buy the ticket
and there is a second situation in which
decided do you decide to see a play for
which admission is $10 as you enter the
theatre you discover that you have lost
the ticket so you bought the ticket and
now the ticket is lost the seat was not
marked and the ticket cannot be
recovered
there is no since you bought the ticket
the seats and and unfortunately the seat
are not marked and there is no way to
recover the ticket would you pay $10 for
a ticket for the play so in which of
these chances and which of these cases
are you more happier or are you more
likeable to buy a second ticket what is
the answer what do you think is going to
happen now given the fact that if these
are the choices which have been
presented it has been found that choice
2 in choice 2 people are more reluctant
people do not want to buy a new ticket
the reason being that they believe that
$10 the value $10
although the ticket has retained their
value at only $10 has been already
assigned to the
and so is the ticket is lost there is no
point in buying a ticket because the
$10.00 from the psychological Money
account that they have that has which
was assigned to the ticket has been lost
but in the first case the idea that $10
bill the $10.00 rupees or the 10 rupees
for which the ticket is worth that got
lost and so that the probability of
losing a 10 rupees is far greater than
the probability of losing a ticket to a
particular play which is of $10 and so
the fact that in in case one in the
first option you are more likely to go
ahead and buy the ticket then in the
second case because here the value of 10
has been assigned to the ticket and the
ticket has been lost and so the value 10
has been assigned to the ticket and in
your psychological accounting says that
I do not want to pay more money to this
particular ticket and so this is what
Daniel Kahneman and Tversky also found
out in Drammen and Kowalski in 1981
original study the subjects were less
willing to purchase a ticket in scenario
two now why could this be this could be
because of the fact that the $10 that
the spend in option 2 will be from the
ticket option from the psychological
account which is assigned to the ticket
well in the first case the probability
of losing a $10 is very high so even if
you lose a $10 bill it it could have
been lost anyway and so you will buy a
ticket but in the second case the ticket
which was further for the $10 the ticket
was lost and so the value was assigned
to the ticket and so since you have lost
the ticket you are not going to put any
more money onto it and so this is called
the psychological accounting another
interesting fact
or another interesting phenomena which
is a follow-up of psychological
accounting or prospect theory is
something called sunk cost
it is another feature or rather
phenomena which shows how people show
irrationality in making decisions they
are not rational decision-maker and so
what is sunk cost now in the sunk cost
effect is another interesting variation
of the notion of psychological
accounting what does he say this effect
was demonstrated by our keys and lunar
in 1985 in one of the X
and so let's look at the experiment so
in this experiment what happened is
subjects were to imagine that they
purchase tickets for two different ski
trips so basically two different ski
trips were then subject they actually
brought ticket for both these trips now
one ticket a trip for Wisconsin costed
$50 while the other ticket was a trip to
Michigan which costed $100 now the
scenario made it clear that the trip to
Wisconsin was preferable because it
would be more enjoyable so basically
then there are two trips that you buy a
ticket to a ski trip one is to Wisconsin
and the other is is to Michigan
the Wisconsin cost of the restaurant is
katikut
is $50 the cost of the Michigan ticket
is $100 both are ski trips that are
there but then this information is
provided to you that the Wisconsin trip
is more desirable it is more fun and so
it is both preferable so now you have
decided to go to both the places now
comes a complication where is the
complication a complication arises where
the two trips are fall on the same
weekend
now unfortunately both the trips tend to
come on the same weekend or the same
dates and the tickets are nonrefundable
you cannot go ahead and they find the
particular ticket my question is which
other tickets
are you preferring to go to or which of
the trips are you going to go to and
which is the trip that you are going to
avoid no rationality suggest that this
constant trip is more exciting although
it is of lower value so people should go
for this one and leave the trip to
Michigan which is expensive hundred
dollars but is that what happens no this
is exactly the opposite of it people
actually prefer the non enjoyable trip
because it is expensive and so people
actually go to the Michigan trip and so
this is what the result of Emerson
Travis keys or Arkansas main study is
that they found out that people take the
Michigan the Michigan trip although it
is not enjoyable but it is expensive and
so this is a phenomena which is also
seen in everyday well maybe what we see
is that people throw in money after bad
money so if people lose money they tend
to throw in more money
so if there is something that you have
which is not working and so when you see
that this thing is not working and you
put more money into it for it being
repaired and it doesn't get repaired you
tend to put more money on to it people
do not get into it so some you buy a
particular product it gets defective you
give it to someone for repair now after
the parrot is still not working you tend
to put more money into it to getting
repaired rather than buying a new thing
because it has already costing you more
and so you tend to make some more money
on to it and this is the exact same
phenomena here happens people tend to
put more ornate on to the expensive
option then the expensive option rather
than choosing an option which is a more
enjoyable but lesser value so these are
what is this is to do with what is
prospect theory and how does prospect
theory really was another interesting
theory or another interesting fact in
decision making is the role of effect in
BC's and making or the role of emotion
in decision making so positive and
negative outcome a positive and negative
effect which comes with an outcome is a
feeling of goodness and badness which
comes with an outcome they give us
different different feelings with us and
with predictable implications on disease
and we make so our decisions are not
just in terms of factual information it
is also related to the kind of feeling
that we get after taking a particular
decision after taking a decision or
after choosing a particular alternative
how do we feel about that alternative
also plays a large role or plays a major
role in how people make decisions or how
this is in making it done so affect us
is an important determinant of decision
making and can have a sizable impact on
psychological accounting process so it's
basically the feeling that you have the
kind of pleasure or pain that you get
out of taking a decision that depends or
that decides a lot about how you pick
diseases now has a and rot the stage
2004 they made this point by
highlighting an important dimension of
choice that interacts with effect which
they term as scope they basically came
up with this dimension of choice which
interacted effect and we call this the
scope which refers to the sweep of a
decision or action how much impact will
it have
so basically Hattie and not
rotten stage in 2004 they invented or
they came up with the whole this a whole
new dimension which is called scope
which refers to the sweep of a decision
how do sometimes diseases are made in
terms sometimes of positivity or
negativity or sweep and this is what
they discovered so consider these
particular two things suppose you give
$10 to save one endangered tiger
it feels good now how much would you
give to save forces in endangered tigers
given the fact that you often see people
coming to you saying that see these kind
of animals are endangered they have to
be saved in some way and so we need some
kind of money from you to save these so
if they then they show you some basic
thing give us $10 and we we are going to
save some endangered animal out of it
let us say panda tiger or whatever it is
and so you give some kind of money into
it the fact that for one it is okay but
then he says that you are going to save
for Tigers are you going to pay more
that's the question now how much are you
going to shell out for and saving for
endangered tigers or what is the way in
which your decision process really works
the answer to this question so if you
are giving $10 for saving one tiger
whether you're going to give $40 for
saving four Tigers is the question and
so the answer to this depend on whether
the subjective value derived from saving
tigers is somewhat multiplicative so
basically the kind of value that you
derive that or the kind of utility that
you derive by saving tigers how much
that is
so is it multiplicative or not so saving
one tiger if you are and so this basic
the decision depends on two different
modes of decision-making so basically if
one tiger requires $10 for saving and if
somebody asked you to save for Tigers
are you giving $40 for saving the tiger
and that depends upon how much utility
or how much subjective value derive from
saving these four Tigers now the author
proposes a dual process view of the
relative impact of scope and subjective
value or decision-making they say that
people make these kind of decisions
under two different modes of
decision-making and what is this mode
there is a particular mode which is
called a deliberative mode in
which map onto the conscious reasoning
so when you are into a deliberative mode
or when you are into a conscious mode of
reasoning then if somebody says that
saving one Tiger is $10 saving for
Tigers $40 then you would provide $40
because you reason that one tiger will
require $10 of saving then for Tigers
will be 10 into 4 which is 40 but if you
are functioning on to an effective mode
if you are functioning into one of those
in a way that you feel good about saving
Tigers then saving one tiger is enough
for you and so if you are functioning
into an effective mode we should map on
to an unconscious reasoning in this case
you say that I don't care
I have said Tiger that is the answer and
so one time beat one tiger or four
Tigers I have saved an endangered
species and so $10 is more than enough
and in those cases you don't shell out
more money so in a deliberative mode you
are more prone to giving more money
because you do more calculations and it
maps or from the conscious part of the
brain and so you tend to shell out more
money because you do a calculation but
if it is the feeling which comes with
the decision of saving Tiger if you feel
good by just saving Tiger if that is the
underlying meaning out of it then
whether it is 1 or 4 it doesn't matter
and so in those cases you are take a
different kind of decision altogether so
when we are in a deliberate decision
making more we value things by
calculating 4 is greater than 2 and so
saving for is much better than 2 while
when we are in an effective
decision-making mode we value things by
feeling help Tigers so saving one tiger
is helping Tiger and saving for tiger is
helping tiger
so whether I say 1 or 4 is basically the
feeling which is out of it it is not
that some when you say 4 Tigers the
feeling will be greater
it is not multiplicative but when we are
in a deliberative more we understand
they're saving one tiger and saving for
Tigers are saving two tigers and four
tigers four tires is more then two
tigers so let's give more money and so
their decision will be based on that
kind of an imperative or that kind of a
system but when in an effective mode
once you are in an effective mode it is
the feeling which is of interest to you
it is the fact it is the pleasure that
get when you say what iger's is the kind
of appreciation that you get when you
say what I got and that is all it
matters so it doesn't really matter
whether you're saying one Tiger or
you're saving for Tigers and so it is
saving Tiger which is of importance to
us
so in deliberately decision-making mode
as cop increases subjective value
increases corresponding when in
effective EC and making mode Scoob
doesn't matter nearly as much as
affected by the presence or absence of
first stimulus so scope is basically the
sweep of the decision so in the
deliberative mode the scope has very
less value than in the effective mode it
is all about the scope which is our
there and so people's decision-making
then vary in terms of whether they are
in the deliberative mode or in the
effective mode and their decisions are
affected by the kind of feeling that
they generate in the affective mode it
is the feeling which basically decides
what kind of decision that they are
going to make or what kind of imperative
that you are going to use or what kind
of disease and options that you are
going to do but in terms of the
deliberative mode it is quite different
and so this is the last section onto a
course on cognitive psychology and in
terms of decision-making so basically
what we did in this particular class is
that we saw a extension of one of the
popular theories of decision-making and
this is the descriptive theory so in the
earlier class what we did in the earlier
lecture what we did we looked at a class
of theories which is called the
normative of prescriptive theories which
work in terms of reasoning and rational
decision makers or ideal decision-makers
and it it is called expected utility
theory or it is called the multi
attribute utility theory both these
theories work on the fact that this
isn't making is basically done in terms
of what is the utility of a particular
option choosing a particular option and
what is the probability of that option
coming in and multiplying this gives us
the final basis on which an option
should be choosing these are the
prescriptive theories or these are the
normative theories which are there we
saw that human beings since they do not
have a lot of information available to
them and even if the information is
available to them they cannot be working
as calculators or mental computers so
they make it
now choice additionality and this
irrationality basically happens because
human beings have certain limitations
and so we as humans follow a descriptive
theory are more worldly theory or
decision-making and one of these
theories are the scene making which is
descriptive in nature is something
called the prospect theory so what is
the prospect theory the prospect theory
is a theory which basically goes ahead
and says that gains and losses that
people have have different values so
gains are higher gains
I have lesser pleasure lower losses have
more pain into it so gains and losses
come in different frames they evaluated
in different frames and gains and losses
are thought of differently also prospect
theory proposes the fact that losing and
gaining are basically dependent on the
frame in which a particular option is
presented so if a particular option is
presented in a gain frame then people's
choices will vary whereas if a
particular option is presented in a loss
frame the people's choices will also
vary according to it so reversals of
preferences or reversals choices of
option depending on which frame the
information is presented in gain frame
people are more risk-averse if people do
not want to take risk people always
select certain options whereas when
something is in a loss frame people are
risk-taking they like risk they take
risk and so once something is in a
negative frame when in the last frame
people want to take risk and put more
risk into it and so that is the kind of
decision-making that they tend to take
and then we discussed two other outputs
out of it or two other phenomena related
to the prospect theory one is called
psychological accounting it says that
how you feel about a particular
situation how you feel about a
particular option makes you decide
whether you like that option or not in
contrast to whether it is multiplicative
or it is whether things are rational or
not so it is the basic feeling that
people get of our part of it
the second the option or the second
output to it or the second theory to it
was the sunk cost theory which says that
people always what they tend to do is
take the non desirable option they
always put more money after the bad
option so if even if something cost more
people tend to take the more unlikable
or the more enjoyable journey because
people put more money on to sunk money
that is the way that they like so they
don't do these calculations given the
fact that if they calculate they will
always go for the lesser enjoyable trip
but they tend to go to the more higher
trip which has higher money do it
because they think that says larger
money has been there let's go with this
thing that is one of the things now in
the last section of this particular
lecture we saw how effect of or
basically how getting pleasing or a non
pleasing feeling out of an decision
basically helps you into decision making
or basically as you do making decisions
and so we found out that when people
have a deliberative mode people are in a
conscious mode then they tend to do this
calculating and they are more helping it
is not about feeling that they think
about it is not about the effect which
decides which help them decide a
particular decision which they which
doesn't rule the decision but when
people in an effective mode the kind of
decisions they tend to take is entirely
different but and and they are affected
by the sweep or the scope of the
decision so basically effect then itself
has a major role to play now in terms of
brain physiology it has also been found
that this risk options of framing has
been proved or the the effect of framing
on decision-making has also been proved
in terms of certain brain studies so in
certain brain studies it has been it was
found that people who were presented
options in a positive frame so if some
option was given to them in a positive
frame and people selected and went in
the positive frame people selected those
options which was certain the brain
activity was very less so in if things
were in offer an option if an
alternative was presented in a positive
frame and people selected certain
options people selected those options
which were not presenting risk people
showed
sir brain activity then if they selected
those options which presented some kind
of a risk on non certain options in
contrast to this so basically less
activity was there when they selected
certain options there then if they
selected those opt options which were
non certain in a positive frame but in a
loss frame it was quite the opposite in
a loss frame when people selected those
options which were risk producing less
brain activity was there then people
when people selected those options which
were certain so in a lost frame
risk-taking led to lesser activity of
the brain and more common activity of
the brain which means that decisions a
more thought true this is answer more
like through then in cases in in the
other case in the positive frame where
certain option selections are selecting
those options which was certain which we
get trying to which were very definite
which are very certain or which were
sort of very fixed those in those cases
the activity of the brain was less than
the wind was much calmer then selecting
those options in which it was not in
this the options were not certain so in
this way human beings make decisions and
in this way human beings produce
decisions or make decisions and and they
differ from calculated machines or
economic decision making so basically
using these processes of decision making
either using the prospect theory or
using the other things human beings come
up with diseases and then they make this
this is an under uncertainty and under
risk and based on that when a certain
decision fails they reevaluate it make
another decision make another choice and
then keep on learning from it
this is how the higher order cognitive
function decision-making really works
and this is the last lecture in the
series on decision-making or in this
whole course which is of cognitive
psychology so until we meet again thank
you
[Music]